very interesting polling news I've been
telling you that Joe Biden has been
leading just about every national poll
for the 2020 Democratic primary even
though Joe Biden hasn't actually
announced that he's running in 2020 so
when I've been reporting the numbers to
you I say Bernie's leading among the
candidates who have declared because Joe
hadn't declared but was leading most
polls that has changed because there's a
new Emerson poll which has Bernie
Sanders in the actual lead even ahead of
Joe Biden which is the first poll that
has these numbers Bernie polling 29% to
Joe Biden's 24 then you have this sort
of next here which is Pete Budaj edge
bethe O'Rourke Kamala Harris and
Elizabeth Warren between 7 and 9 percent
then you've got the next tier which is
who Leon Castro
Andrew Yang and Cory Booker with 2 to 3
percent and then you've got the 0 and
ones which includes Eric's Wow well Amy
Klobuchar Mike Gravel Tulsi Gabbard Tim
Ryan etc etc etc so there's a bunch of
people here who are just getting no
traction like they can't seem to get
beyond 1 percent on Friday I'm gonna do
an audience question about who do I
think is going to drop out the soonest
from the 2020 democratic primary so I
won't go into that now but it appears
very clearly Pat that at least at this
early stage you're starting to get some
tears that develop and so far we've not
seen too much movement it's notable that
Pete Buddha jej shortly after announcing
has surged it's notable that Andrew yang
who was basically completely unknown is
now polling 3% ahead of a whole bunch of
people including Tulsi Gabbard and
others but beyond that you've seen this
sort of three-tier system stay pretty
stable over the last couple months
yeah the beauty judge thing is still
surprising to me even though he got that
surge a couple weeks ago I just never
thought that a smaller town mayor would
be able to gain so much traction in a
presidential race but he has and he's an
intelligent guy and I think he'll still
be able to hold that support and he
could be an actual contender the other
surprise to me was who Leon Castro at 3
I mean 3% isn't too much but he's on par
with Andrew yang there that that's
pretty good at this stage it's
particularly good because he's been
getting almost no attention so that's
also why it's sort of surprising to me
now this Emerson poll also asked a
really interesting question they asked
Joe Biden voters because remember Joe
Biden has a lot of support but isn't
actually running they said if Joe Biden
doesn't run who do you support
and if Joe Biden didn't run Bernie gains
the most 31% of Biden supporters said if
Biden's a no-go we go to Bernie 17% of
Biden supporters said if Biden doesn't
run we go to Mayor Pete and 13% of Biden
supporters supporters said they'd go to
bed oh if Biden doesn't run lastly from
the poll I hesitate to even do this
because it's so early and I'm trying to
stay away from electability stuff but
it's in the poll and it's interesting
they did hypothetical matchups between
Trump and other candidates or possible
candidates Biden the strongest over
Trump 53 to 47 followed by Bernie 51 to
48 over Trump beto 51 to 49 and then
Harris Budaj and Warren even or down a
pointer to to Donald Trump now I want to
be like really really clear all these
numbers are so close that they're within
the margin of error and when the numbers
are this close turnout alone can swing
it and what I mean by that is even if
right now in this poll bernie is a point
ahead of Harris relative to trump if
Harris can turn out just marginally more
people in key states she could do better
than Bernie against Donald Trump that's
a hypothetical example so the the main
takeaways right now
Bernie continuing to climb Budaj edge
making a very strong entrance Andrew
yang interestingly starting from one of
the weaker positions candidate wise in
terms of how many people know who he is
up to 3% and a lot of people just
getting no traction whatsoever let me
know what you think about these numbers
let me know what you think about how
closely we should even be paying
attention to them at this early point in
the primary quick break follow me on
instagram at david pakman
and we will be back right after this if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video